[Música]
en nuestra sección de economía
hablaremos del viaje que está haciendo
el canciller Alemán olafels por América
Latina Juan Pablo lucumís buenos días
cómo está Muy buenos días Muy bien y
usted muy bien gracias empecemos
entonces
quiero que tiene shorts en la región
María Clara arrancamos semana y
arrancamos con noticias empezamos con el
tema que usted está hablando el sábado
del canciller alemán firmó en Buenos
Aires Argentina un memorando de
entendimiento que pretende asegurar el
acceso de Berlín a los recursos de litio
en el país y es que solo para darle un
ejemplo la Automotriz alemana BMW
extraer el llamado oro blanco Desde hace
dos años del salar del hombre muerto
esto en catamarca Argentina bueno y
precisamente para eso vino no para
buscar recursos energéticos Así es María
Clara en palabras del canciller su
objetivo es abro comillas trabajar más
específicamente con nuestros socios en
América Latina y el Caribe energía
renovables hidrógeno verde y comercio
responsable de materias primas valoramos
mucho las habilidades y el potencial de
nuestros socios allí estamos buscando
asociaciones a la altura de los ojos y
llenas de respeto Nuestro objetivo es
establecer conjuntamente prioridades
para la protección global del clima el
medio ambiente y la biodiversidad para
la descarbonización y la transformación
ecológica de nuestras industrias Ese es
el objetivo básicamente y usted estaba
mencionando mw Y es que en la región hay
riqueza de varios materiales sobre todo
el litio que es fundamental para esto no
es así así es María Clara mirémoslo en
términos de proveedores mundiales de
litio porque ese insumo es indispensable
como lo decía usted para baterías de
vehículos eléctricos que ahora la Unión
Europea está usando y que Está avanzando
todo esto Pues con sus objetivos de 2030
de los primeros cuatro proveedores
mundiales del oro blanco dos están en
América Latina hablamos de chile como
segundo y Argentina solo superado por
china que pues el gigante asiático Esta
es una de las grandes razones de la
visita de choles porque pues tener
socios en América Latina también le
permite hacerle frente a China y pues de
acaparar básicamente gran parte de la
economía mundial que es uno de los
objetivos de los cuales también se habló
en el Foro de davos ahora se espera que
el canciller llegue a Brasil siendo el
primer gran líder occidental en reunirse
con el presidente brasileño Lula da
Silva desde su reelección y tal como
usted lo dice y Podemos mirar también en
la gráfica
Argentina como una posible solución al
monopolio que tiene China en en
internacionalmente no exactamente Te
propongo que cambiemos de tema y nos
vayamos a España porque ya se conocieron
los datos de la inflación Cómo le fue
María Clara los precios subieron en
enero el índice de precios al consumidor
se ubicó este mes en 5,8% interanual una
décima más que la tasa de diciembre
cuando fue del 5,7% según los datos
publicados este lunes por el Instituto
Nacional de estadística la entidad
atribuyó el aumento de precios al costo
del combustible a pues ya que el
gobierno eliminó el subsidio general a
todos los combustibles mientras que los
precios de la ropa y el calzado no
cayeron tan rápido como durante enero de
2022 los datos de la economía española
llegan justo cuando el Banco Central
europeo Se comprometió públicamente en
davos a subir sus tasas de interés como
medida para contener la inflación y
sigamos revisando Econo europeas
especialmente la más fuerte del viejo
continente Alemania cómo está este país
salió el dato más reciente del producto
interno bruto de Alemania que muestra
que en el cuarto trimestre de 2022 la
economía del país se contrajo un 0,2% En
comparación con el trimestre anterior
esta es la primera contracción de la
economía alemana desde el primer
trimestre de 2021 en gran parte debido a
una disminución en el gasto del
consumidor que había respaldado la
economía en los primeros 9 meses esto el
año pasado la previsión de los
economistas para el pib era del 0,0 por
ciento pero con el resultado negativo
Ahora ven de forma inminente una
recesión para la economía más grande de
Europa Pues también se espera una
contracción del pib para este primer
trimestre del año pero ya veremos qué
pasará estaremos hablando de esto en
marzo y claramente le haremos
seguimiento como siempre lo hacemos aquí
en France 24 ustedes bien lo decía
primer día de la semana lunes Cuáles son
los indicadores entonces pues estamos a
la espera de la apertura de Wall stre
los inversores hablando desde ya de las
decisiones de la reserva Federal esto el
próximo miércoles y con el anuncio de
ganancias de Samsung que planea reducir
su producción mundial de chips ahora
vamos hacia hacia precisamente porque
las acciones cerraron mixtas luego de
que se conociera que los ingresos
Fiscales de China aumentaron un
0,6% en 2022 respecto al año anterior
desacelerándose drásticamente desde el
alza del 10,7% en 2021 las bolsas
europeas siguen operando
mayoritariamente en terreno mixto
mientras el euro gana fuerza frente al
Dólar y cuál es la cifra del día pues la
cifra del día Ya vamos para deportes
pero vamos a hablar un poco de ellos es
un millón
952.245 euros casi 2 millones de euros
es decir que pues eso es lo que se está
ganando en este momento el tenista
serbio Nova Djokovic por haber ganado el
Abierto de Australia en 2023 esa cifra
en un solo día usted cree que se va a
ganar eso en toda su vida de trabajo ya
veremos
los datos Está bastante complicado no
pero bueno Gracias Juan Pablo por toda
la economía volvemos en una hora Ahora
volvemos con más